les neuf organisations syndicales des
métiers de la justice ne s'était pas
unis depuis 2011
seulement face au projet gouvernemental
de réforme la mobilisation s'impose pour
les syndicats mot d'ordre une justice de
qualité
la garde des sceaux mme belloubet a
décidé de mettre en place cinq chantiers
pour rénover l'institution judiciaire et
au vu des rapports qui ont été déposés
elle nous a demandé quels étaient les
lignes rouges à ne pas franchir et il se
trouve que les professionnels de la
justice que sont les fonctionnaires les
magistrats les avocats ont décidé ces
neuf organisations ont décidé de se
rassembler pour dire nous ne voulons pas
sur la base des propositions qui sont
faites
la réforme que vous pensez nous proposer
les syndicats parlent de déficit humains
matériels et immobilier selon eux une
centaine de magistrats manque à la cour
d'appel de versailles
les pannes informatiques on perdra temps
difficiles à rattraper et les locaux
sont vétustes
ici à versailles tout à chacun peut
passer devant le palais de justice et
voir qu'il ya un grand filet qui protège
le bâtiment parce que nous n'avons même
plus les moyens de maintenir nos murs en
état nous pour informer les citoyens et
parler de ses mouvements au sens de la
justice
les syndicats ont prévu de mettre en
place des réunions publiques dans les
yvelines dans les jours à venir